if a store wants to sell more of
something there are many things that can
do signs could be placed around the
store to advertise a specific aisle and
ads could attract people with coupons
but small imperceptible changes can work
just as well and at a fraction of the
cost it's a concept called nudging that
more and more companies are hiring
psychologists to study and use instead
of advertising directly they might paint
the toothpaste aisle with a reflective
coating to you and I this would seem
like a meaningless design decision but
as customers walked by they see
themselves including their teeth
reflected in the mirrored shelves a few
steps later they're more likely to put
some whitening toothpaste in their cart
if asked why they bought it people might
make up a reason or maybe admit that
they didn't like the look of their teeth
but they wouldn't suspect that the store
planned it nudging can come in a million
different tiny forms one section of a
grocery store might be better lit making
you move in its direction or more
profitable items might be placed on
shelves at eye level making them easier
to see but they can also be the heart of
a business Costco is designed more like
a warehouse than a store it's designed
specifically not to be convenient
because while you're running around
trying to find something you'll spot
some other things to buy as well
gems push hard for memberships but then
nudge you away the more equipment is
used the more often it needs fixed or
replaced and the less money they make
gyms aren't designed for your comfort
it's just the opposite the ideal
customer feels guilty enough to keep
paying for his membership but
uncomfortable enough to avoid going now
if you believe that our brains will
eventually be fully understood by
scientists then there are no limits to
how much people could be nudged
companies will have a blueprint to your
brain with a recipe that will guarantee
your purchase of anything but even if
not our brains can still be influenced
assume that companies will keep wanting
money and psychologists will continue
better understanding the brain and at
some point nudging will become not just
suggestion but active manipulation
Amazon won't just predict what's on your
shopping list they'll actually create it
so where should we draw the line between
nudging as just another marketing
strategy and unjust coercion many people
would draw the line at
Option companies can push you to buy
more bananas but if they're honest about
their methods it isn't so bad a store
might place a sign at the entrance that
says we use psychological research to
help you buy the best products a very
corporate statement but a fair warning
that people can recognize but being told
the flaws of your brain is not enough to
prevent them I can tell you that all of
these dots are white and you can really
believe me but that won't stop your
brain from seeing otherwise so why
should simply telling someone make it
acceptable when the manipulation still
works unless the brain can be and is
completely understood companies will
have to estimate the effectiveness of
their nudges just like any advertising
campaign they won't know exactly on who
or how well a nudge will work only an
overall success rate it's hard to say
what exact percentage is too high that
would always seem arbitrary but some
would say as long as there's some amount
of choice involved then it's more
marketing than manipulation but this too
is arbitrary sure a store doesn't know
if you will buy something but some
number of people will for them the nudge
was responsible for the purchase not
their free choice the simple answer is
that it all depends on what people are
being nudged towards if people are
pushed to buy healthy and helpful
products it's okay but if it's used to
harm them then it's not but this too has
flaws stores can't be trusted to make
this judgement themselves so governments
have to decide what moral and immoral
purchases look like and even if we could
make that distinction we would still
lack any sense of freedom it's the same
reason we don't outlaw everything
unhealthy we value choice whether we
consider something good or not the
interesting thing is that a lot of these
points also apply to advertising
generally it too manipulates our brains
against our will so is advertising just
as bad or is nudging more deceptive
either way there's no way to avoid these
questions because there's really no way
to stop nudging a store has to be
designed some way so companies have no
choice but to nudge in some direction
even unintentionally so what do you
think what's the difference between a
good and a bad nudge is there one at all
if you're like me
the news is so frustrating you've kind
of just stopped paying attention I could
make a whole video on everything wrong
with news sites ads cover 90% of your
screen but they make you disable adblock
there's so much bias and they put the
good articles behind a paywall
but there's a way to get the news
without all of that compass news is a
news website that's actually worth
reading you get articles from sites like
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
Wired and The Economist but without the
ads without the paywall
and completely free they write summaries
so you can quickly get just the most
important information even if you only
have a few moments you can just glance
at their iOS or Android app they also
understand that no source can be 100%
neutral so they present different
viewpoints in one place it's really the
opposite of clickbait the goal is to
actually make you like the site so
you'll come back not show you whatever
it takes to generate ad revenue imagine
that compass news is vc-backed meaning
they're getting funding to build the
business so you might as well take
advantage by using the service for free
sign up at Compass news co uk slash poly
matter pol y ma tter and that'll help me
by showing that I sent you it only takes
a few seconds to sign up and if you
don't like it you can just leave thanks
to compass news for sponsoring this
video
[Music]